[Música]
los 20 acusados por los atentados
terroristas de parís en 2015 fueron
condenados la mayor sentencia fue para
sala abdeslam el único sobreviviente de
la unidad yihadista el pagar a cadena
perpetua esos ataques fueron los más
mortíferos en francia desde la segunda
guerra mundial
la otan considera que rusia es la mayor
amenaza directa para la seguridad de
occidente
organización ratificó su apoyo a kiev y
acordó un plan para modernizar a las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas también
invitó formalmente a suecia y a
finlandia a ser parte del grupo rusia
dijo que respondería ante las amenazas
el primer ministro de israel naftalí
bennett no aspirará a la reelección y es
que se espera que haya una nueva
votación parlamentaria la quinta que ha
habido en tan solo cuatro años ya que el
legislativo está a punto de disolverse
ampliamos desde jerusalén
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
estar con ustedes comenzamos en francia
después de 10 meses de audiencias este
miércoles la justicia condenó a los 20
acusados dentro del proceso por los
ataques terroristas de parís en 2015 los
atentados fueron los más mortíferos en
el país desde la segunda guerra mundial
pues en ellos 130 personas perdieron la
vida dos de los responsables pagarán
cadena perpetua luís muñoz tiene todos
los detalles
casi siete años después justicia el
tribunal especial de parís condenó a
sala a abdeslam la cadena perpetua es la
quinta sentencia máxima en la historia
de francia y fue para el único
perpetrador superviviente de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre en parís y
sant dennis murieron 130 personas en la
mayor matanza en francia desde la
segunda guerra mundial del resto de
acusados otros 19 fueron reconocidos
culpables de todos sus cargos menos uno
que solo fue condenado por el delito de
concierto para delinquir
tenemos la sensación después del
veredicto de que estamos pasando página
las licencias por enviadas no son
excesivas se adaptan tanto a los hechos
como a que los cometieron uc y eso
quieres un cómic para las víctimas esta
sentencia también supone el fin de una
etapa después de años esperando este
momento podrán respirar
pero antes de pensar en las secuelas ya
la digerir pero hemos terminado un
primer ciclo y ahora hay que pensar en
el siguiente todavía espero poder
conjugar la palabra víctima del pasado
pero no estoy satisfecho con la
sentencia y creo igual que mucha gente
que es justa no hay que exagerar no hay
que pedir más pero yo creo que todo lo
he hecho ha sido de acuerdo con la ley y
eso es buena y todo lo que es igual
el juicio ha durado nueve meses ahora
los acusados podrán apelar a una
sentencia escrita de 120 páginas que
recibirán el jueves luego de que se
conocieran las sentencias por los
atentados de parís el ex presidente
françois hollande publicó una carta en
la que recibe el veredicto y afirma que
se reivindicaron los valores de la
democracia francesa quien entonces era
el mandatario del país agregó que el
juicio le permitirá a todas las
generaciones futuras no olvidar las
consecuencias del fanatismo de los
terroristas hollande también le habló a
las víctimas
al dar voz a las víctimas durante meses
para tener todos los testimonios y hacer
un balance del sufrimiento y el dolor y
al solicitar la presencia de todos los
actores de esta tragedia la justicia
permitió buscar la verdad para entender
mejor el camino del terrorismo islamista
en españa se realiza el segundo día de
la cumbre de la otan a los países
miembros de la alianza militar
consideran que rusia es la mayor amenaza
para occidente en este momento y
reiteraron su apoyo a ucrania como parte
del refuerzo eeuu enviar a más militares
a las naciones europeas que hacen parte
de la otan especialmente a las que están
más cerca de rusia canadá a españa y
noruega tomaron decisiones similares
se trata de un delicado equilibrio para
los dirigentes de la otan dejar que sus
miembros armen a ucrania sin provocar un
enfrentamiento directo con una rusia que
cuenta con armas nucleares selenski y
lleva meses pidiendo el apoyo de las
democracias occidentales una llamada a
la que los líderes mundiales decidieron
responder en la cumbre de la otan en
madrid y nuestra respuesta fue sí que
estamos preparados porque están luchando
por su independencia pero también están
luchando por valores que son importantes
para el auto
para pasar de las palabras a los hechos
eeuu refuerza su posición militar en
europa del este como primera fuerza
militar de la otan 100.000 tropas
estadounidenses están actualmente
estacionadas en europa y se prevé que
aumenten especialmente en el este vaivén
también desplegará más aeronaves en
reino unido- y aumentará su flota naval
en españa
pons con sus o menos tan yo creo que
esta cumbre es la oportunidad de
coordinar nuestros esfuerzos para
garantizar la seguridad de nuestro
espacio
a nuestro espacio otros países están
siguiendo el ejemplo de eeuu canadá se
comprometió a enviar tropas a letonia
noruega también dijo que donaría tres
sistemas de cohetes de lanzamiento
múltiple a ucrania la otan en su
conjunto tiene previsto multiplicar por
siete el número de tropas en alerta
máxima pasando de 40.000 a 300.000
también abordaron cuestiones que van más
allá de las fronteras de europa en
particular el fortalecimiento de la
región del indo pacífico así como
abordar los desafíos de china y las
amenazas del programa nuclear de corea
del norte
otro de los anuncios de la otan es que
invitaron formalmente a suecia y a
finlandia a ser parte del grupo luego de
que turquía levantara su veto rusia
respondió que no tiene problema en que
esos países se unan a la alianza militar
pero que si la otan despliega militares
e infraestructura en las naciones
escandinavas los rusos responderán de la
misma manera y es que finlandia es uno
de los países que más fronteras comparte
con territorio ruso con más de 1300 km
estas fueron las palabras de vladimir
putin y
con respecto a finlandia y suecia no
tenemos el tipo de problemas que
desafortunadamente tenemos con ucrania y
su creíble hojas ni edwin territoriales
otros fines por lo tenemos disputas
territoriales con ellos no hay nada que
pueda preocuparnos en términos de que
finlandia y suecia se conviertan en
miembros de la otan
si quieren adelante
pero deben entender claramente que no
enfrentaría ninguna amenaza antes de eso
ahora si se despliegan las tropas y la
infraestructura de la otan teniendo
fin/ford estructura muy bueno siendo
emblemático nos veremos obligados a
responder de la misma manera y crear las
mismas amenazas al territorio y ahora
nos están creando a nosotros
noticias de la guerra en ucrania del
presidente volodymyr selenski informó
que intercambiaron 144 soldados
ucranianos por la misma cantidad de
rusos detenidos es el mayor canje de
prisioneros que ha habido hasta ahora 95
de los liberados defendieron la acería
de mariupol en la que el grupo militar
ha soft ganó popularidad este grupo
nació por líderes ultra nacionalistas y
ahora respalda al ejército ucraniano
ellos accedieron a hablar con las
enviadas especiales de france 24 leticia
álvarez e irene sabio bajo la condición
de que no revelaremos sus coordenadas
son las fuerzas especiales integradas en
el batallón de azor una nueva división
que lucha en primera línea y en las
operaciones más expuestas de la guerra
de ucrania entrarán en distintas
localizaciones para evitar ser
descubiertos
tempo trabajamos como grupo de
reconocimiento y sabotaje nuestra tarea
es destruir equipos mano de obra y minas
limpiar minas realizar reconocimientos
dirigir la artillería o liberar pueblos
si la situación lo requiere podemos
llevar a cabo la defensa de pueblos
un batallón polémico por su pasado
paramilitar de líderes ultra
nacionalistas y extremistas que utilizan
símbolos nazis su comandante lo niega
estas son las fantasías de algunas
personas sobre el hecho de que fue
creado a partir de personas ultra
nacionalistas los miembros de la unidad
eran personas patrióticas que amaban su
país a su estado y su cultura han sido
utilizados por vladimir putin para
acusar a ucrania de nazi en numerosas
ocasiones son mediáticos saben utilizar
las redes sociales y la batalla de
lacería de mariupol ha hecho crecer su
fama
digámoslo así se trata de una unidad de
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania todos los
participantes tienen experiencia de
combate muchos de ellos pasaron por el
as off de mariupol algunos se han
retirado google y su red news peer scrum
el batallón de azov sigue entrenándose
indefinidamente entre bosques y colinas
para preparar a los nuevos combatientes
que luchan en el este de ucrania
ucrania nos vamos a israel el primer
ministro naftalí bennett afirmó que no
aspirará a una reelección en los
próximos comicios es que el parlamento
está a punto de disolverse luego de que
bennett promoviera el cambio legislativo
tras las luchas internas que le
impidieron gobernar en coalición esta
sería la quinta de elección en menos de
cuatro años nuestro corresponsal en
jerusalén federico cue barberena nos
explica qué está ocurriendo en la
política israelí
con apenas poco más de un año en el
cargo de primer ministro de israel
naftalí bennett anunció que no buscará
su reelección y que se alejara de la
función pública cuando se forme el nuevo
gobierno aunque no se trata de algo
definitivo porque en sus palabras servir
a israel es su destino además se
confirmó que su partido político ya mina
será liderado por el jaked actual
ministra de interior es una figura del
ala más dura de esta formación
derechista que se ha mostrado dispuesta
a formar un gobierno con el ex primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu y que podría
convertirse en una jugadora clave en el
futuro político israelí y aunque benítez
dio su mensaje de despedida deberá
permanecer en el cargo por al menos un
día más luego de que la que necesite el
parlamento israelí fallar en su objetivo
de disolverse antes de la medianoche del
miércoles tras una jornada de intensos
idas y vueltas a los legisladores
aplazaron la resolución para el jueves
por la mañana también deberán fijar la
fecha de las nuevas elecciones las
quintas en tres años y medio algo en lo
que tampoco hay acuerdo la oposición
prefiere que sean el 25 de octubre y el
oficialismo el primero de noviembre en
el centro de los desencuentros tantos
proyectos de que la coalición considera
clave aprobar antes de la disolución del
parlamento 1 allanaría el camino para
que los israelíes tengan una extensión
de visados para viajar a estados unidos
y el otro avanzaría en un sistema de
metro para tel aviv y sus alrededores
pero ambos proyectos están estancados
entre una oposición que no quiere
entregar victorias al gobierno antes de
las elecciones y los propios algunos
partidos de la formación de gobierno que
buscan en ganar tiempo y forzar la
aprobación de estos proyectos en este
escenario y sin la que necesiten logra
disolverse el jueves yair lapid el
actual ministro de exteriores- asumirá
de manera formal como primer ministro
interino de israel en los primeros
minutos del viernes
pasamos a noticias latinoamericanas en
mexico mataron a otro periodista el
reportero número 12 que asesinan en lo
que va del año en ese país según la
sociedad interamericana de prensa se
trata de antonio de la cruz quien
trabajaba para el periódico expreso le
dispararon cuando salía de su casa en
ciudad victoria ubicada en el noreste
mexicano la cip sostiene que 2022 ya es
uno de los años más letales para los
periodistas de esta nación
en nicaragua la asamblea nacional
canceló las personalidades jurídicas de
otras 101 ongs con lo que se eleva a 758
las organizaciones ilegalizadas en el
país los parlamentarios oficialistas
consideraron que las entidades no
cumplen con todos los requisitos de la
ley de lavado de activos pero la
oposición de las acciones como una
persecución pues las ilegalizaciones han
sido solicitadas por el gobierno de
daniel ortega especialmente después de
las protestas antigubernamentales de
vuelve a haber espuma tóxica cerca a la
capital de colombia bogotá esta vez la
nube de espuma cubrió al menos 30 casas
en el municipio de soacha las
autoridades locales explicaron que
analizarán las muestras para determinar
qué causó esto imágenes similares se
vieron en el vecino municipio de
mosquera a finales de abril por la
contaminación de un río
a propósito de aguas contaminadas en
lisboa continúan la segunda conferencia
sobre los océanos donde no solo discuten
cómo limpiar los mares y las costas sino
también los efectos de la crisis
climática y es que uno de los
ecosistemas más afectados son los
arrecifes de corales que fue
precisamente uno de los temas de la
jornada de hoy en la cumbre nuestra
enviada especial marina colorado nos
cuenta la historia
gran parte de la conferencia de los
océanos se celebra fuera del recinto
donde las delegaciones dan sus discursos
y hoy se llevó a cabo una carrera contra
la extinción de los arrecifes de coral
donde organizaciones públicas y privadas
se reunieron para poner el foco en estos
ecosistemas que tanto sufren los
impactos del cambio climático y del
calentamiento global una carrera contra
el tiempo a bordo de un velero con
mensajes en sus velas sobre el aumento
de las temperaturas y la desaparición de
los arrecifes de coral unos lienzos
hechos de materiales reciclados
representantes de kenia país con ficción
junto con portugal de la conferencia de
los océanos hablaron de como estos
eventos crean conciencia mientras que el
programa de desarrollo de las naciones
unidas recalcó como sus programas
podrían ayudar a estos ecosistemas
los arrecifes de coral son el corazón de
la economía del océano o economía sur y
la economía azul es el corazón de la
salud del planeta y del crecimiento y
bienestar del planeta que a su vez es la
clave de nuestra salud y bienestar ahora
los informes es practicase nuestra
promesa por el océano se basa en nuestra
visión de la economía incluye no sólo
restaurar con ayuda de nuestros aliados
el billón de dólares en pérdidas
socioeconómicas que el mal manejo del
océano ha causado sino también crear un
sustento y vida es decir océanos limpios
lutz en life clean air rose jones unas
ayudas que los corales necesitan
desesperadamente puesto que la mitad de
estos ecosistemas han desaparecido en
los últimos 50 años y se estima que sin
acciones urgentes el resto podría
extinguirse en las próximas tres décadas
aquí las noticias sigan con nosotros
[Música]